hallo mein name ist so herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge stars
table mir die kommentare geschrieben hey
luca du musst mal wieder stars david
socken nach meinem letzten video waren
aber irgendwie ein paar server down
deswegen konnte ich das nicht aufnehmen
an dieser stelle möchte ich mich dafür
entschuldigen
viele leute haben mich dafür beleidigt
weil es aufgenommen habe und irgendwie
server 1 und 4 milliarden nicht mehr
sonne bewahren weil die alle das spiel
spielt wollte ich bin wieder drin mit
relais motto summer rain und mir wurde
gesagt es ist wohl so dass ich gegen ihn
jetzt mal was machen muss es gibt wohl
die möglichkeit dass man irgendwelche
rennen macht wird die möglichkeit dass
man irgendwelche kurs macht sich aber
viele bob die ganze welt irgendwie zu
entdecken und wo war klar da bin ich
gerade unter geräten kann ich irgendwie
auf das boot hier drauf ist gefährlich
gestürzt aber auf mysteriöse weise
gekommen
was ist er denn ich werde nicht mehr
hallo wird willst du dir oh mein gott
man kann darauf herr kollege konnte
schreibt das weg gehen dann wird durch
den durchgedrehten was sind dass ihr
bald für menschen
ich werde ich endlich meine
arbeitsstelle
dies einfach weg kann ich mit den
menschen hier eigentlich irgendwie reden
wenn ich irgendwie auf die drauf clique
oder so dass sie mir sagen was ist die
komischen schaltet man dass da hinten
lauf summer rain dahin nation geschöpfen
landratsamt richtig scheiße ich weiß
überhaupt nicht was der sinn von diesem
spiel ist und was ich jetzt auch mann
samuel ist fast tot nicht krank werden
luca ich weiß nur nicht wo ich jetzt
irgendwie geld verdienen kann oder
irgendwie rennen bestreiten kann oder
noch mehr sachen lernen kann weil ich
bin aber ich bin wieder zu hause ein
paar sekunden später sah man reinsteckt
tatsächlich gerade in wien fest ja
willst du da vielleicht doch mal
rauskommen hey freunde tag ich bin mir
der tat angekommen ich war nur begrüßen
und politik verrückte zuliebe haben über
und auch nach nachfragen richtig hält
wenn du dich verlässt oder einfach
zurück zum steinberg sein kann zu den
abholservice
es gibt folglich abholservice elena
braucht etwas das ich ein wenig mehr
herausfordert stimmt richtig ich nehme
diesen auftrag an und muss jetzt
tatsächlich wo muss ich denn hin ich bin
gerade gegen zum handels dings ich weiß
aber nicht ich kann sachen kaufen ich
habe aber ich hab' ich habe 35 münzen
ich will einfach nur noch mal wissen wo
ich jetzt genau hin muss weil ich habe
überhaupt keinen plan wo ich hin wo es
hallo du komisches ding holen gehe ich
hätte nie gedacht dass ich jemals mit
ihr in kontakt treten könnte darf ich
mit dir aufnehmen wenn ich lieb bin ich
kaufe auch deine merge alles klar
aufnahme ist geregelt hallo mein name
ist so jan luca willkommen stars der
wollte nur sagen dass deine videos liebe
oder tomatensaft es ist nämlich so ein
bisschen das problem und zwar nachdem
ich jetzt erstmal stars der will
aufgenommen habe das finde ich übrigens
mal hier
da könnt ihr es noch mal anschauen die
stars denn immer mehr wie ich mich
geschlagen hat und seitdem habe ich sehr
viele nachrichten tatsächlich im
postfach ich weiß nicht ob da leute mir
auch irgendwie geschenke gemacht haben
oder sogar auf die mir einfach nur
geschrieben haben und da kann man echt
so viele leute an die irgendwie mein
joker du [ __ ] ich kann nie wieder
zocken weil du alles kaputt gemacht hat
und so was ich bin loretta und wer bist
du das tut mir ja irgendwo leid aber
andererseits kann ich natürlich nichts
für wenn ich bei jedem spiel so
reagieren würde dann wirklich nichts
mehr aufnehmen
was hat sie mir denn jetzt eigentlich
mitgeteilt
doch quatsch du bist immer noch ich
hätte dir schon gesagt das gründliche
koppel ausprobieren kann
also ehrlich losgeht zum startpunkt zum
joker im rennen wissen die dass sich ein
kompletter spaß den rennen bin gut ok
haben wir einen lauf stellte vorsitzende
normales wettessen weil das kann's ja
gut so hier um die ecke reiten und
samaria hören gibt's konzern hier mein
gott ist das mein gott alter das ist
dass ich doch das wird gut sonst laufen
wir herum und da ist das ziel und
ich kann rennen doch so raven child
absolviert da hinten gerade ein rennen
und sie kommt glaube ich jeden moment
auch an mir vorbeigelaufen so ich bin
der größte berg at ist durch eine falle
gelaufen ja hier loretta ich habe dein
rennen absolviert was sagt okay das war
nicht schlecht für einen anfänger halt's
maul war richtig gut ich werde sie dir
zeigen abgeschlossen habe geld bekommen
bis dem wasser war wo kann ich denn
jetzt muss das hinkommen da mal wieder
die tandy darum steht sollten hallo ich
bin terno retter die gezeigt wie man
bleiben kannst es gerne versuchen pass
auf die gew baustelle auf werte haben
angst bei den baumaschinen also komme
ihnen nicht zu nahe ja mach ich doch war
ich da nicht schon wieder ja als wenn
doch im rennen alter vom summer rain das
ist natürlich gar keinen link für uns
wir müssen auch mein gott nein das ist
einsteins amarell zusammenhang auf die
strecke um die kurve dann hier unter den
bäumen her hier lang also ich muß ich
sagen bei der map haben die sich
gedanken gemacht das sieht echt alles
ist schlüssig um neues aus 2000 jahre
später hat er das rennen ist unglaublich
lange also ich leite die ganze zeit lang
hier zwischen den pfeilern herforder
noch ist sie irgendwie gar kein ziel
eine ewigkeit später hier um die uhr
bereit
dann kommt hier wieder von außen rein in
die kur war ich beim rennfahrer training
gelernt von innen die kurve nehmen
hier lange vorne noch
das war richtig scheiße okay dass man
nicht unbedingt von tasche ist aber dass
sich tapfer geschlagen ist natürlich
noch evita semmering selbst schneller
wird grund aufwirbeln und so geht das ja
die ganze zeit weiter das teil und
loretta für mich verschiedene aufgaben
haben dass ich meiner spiele slice und
cool und es ist meist design und ich bin
mit all meinen besten freundinnen wie
beispielsweise identisches kassiert dann
bin ich auf einem server in cannes mit
den auch guck mal das ganze neue joint
was geht mannheim alles klar bei dir mit
den allen bin ich auf dem server körper
die sportler überhaupt nicht überall gut
einschlafen dabei trotzdem bin ich in
der roda teil schon sehr bald deswegen
würde ich sagen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich um eine
bewertung von wollte vielleicht noch ein
paar zdebel in zwei monaten bis man es
dann wieder zocken
sonst sehen wir uns in einem nächsten
video wieder wenn ihr das video gerade
seht bin ich noch in wien und loggt euch
wahrscheinlich gar nicht